last question today hey David when are
you going to formally decide who you're
supporting in the 2020 Democratic
primary I don't have a date we need all
the candidates first right and we also
need time for all of the candidates to
figure out what their positions are on a
variety of different important issues so
number one I'm just not going to decide
until it's clear that we have all of the
serious candidates that we're going to
have right now we don't even know who
the serious candidates are although we
can get an idea based on who they are as
people we need to wait to ensure that we
are choosing I think it's important to
choose candidates that are actually on
the ballot in enough states to get 270
electoral votes there are people who get
on the ballot in a couple of states but
aren't even running formally in enough
states to get 270 electoral votes and
when the presidency I'm not interested
in voting for those people because the
the number-one priority is we've got to
get Trump out right and it would not
make sense to support someone who can't
even actually win health care is an
issue where you're seeing so far every
candidate pay lip service to Medicare
for all but some are already backing off
of it so we need to see debates so I
don't know when it is that I'm going to
make the determination as to who I'm
supporting but it's certainly not now
because we need all of the candidates
who are running to say that they're
running I need to start digging in in
more depth to their final platforms I I
may even want to see some debates before
I fully decide and I'm not shy about
telling you that the people I'm most
interested in right now are Elizabeth
Warren and Andrew yang at this point I I
want to see if Bernie's running I want
to see what actually happens during
debates and are people softening on
policies that I think are the most
important so I'm not in any particular
rush I have never been one of these late
undecideds when it's September and you
don't know who you're supporting that's
weird
that I don't understand how that's
possible now of course that's the
general election and likewise if it's
two weeks before the end of
for your state votes in the primary or
caucus and you still don't know I quite
frankly also think that's weird like it
should if you're paying attention you
you should really have been able to
figure that out with plenty of time
remaining before it's time to vote so
I'll let you know I am not playing coy
in the sense of hiding who I'm leaning
towards I've been clear about who's most
appealing to me right now and I assure
you you will know it when I make a
decision as to as to who I'm supporting
we've got a great bonus show for you
today
what is the bonus show the bonus show is
another show every day we do this show
and then we do another show for our paid
subscribers and you can access that by
being a member you can sign up at join
pakman.com that's www.jfn.co.jp/toho at
medCom the other David Pakman owns
pakman.com so it's
www.en.sheikhsalah.com FB